by teasing but not quite confirming a
presidential run in 2024 Donald Trump
says he doesn't want to detract from
these midterm elections but his
fingerprints are all over them if you
thought that Donald Trump was
yesterday's man then you've simply not
been paying attention he is the driving
force behind today's Republican Party
he's endorsed almost 300 candidates in
races across this country casting his
vote alongside wife Melania in the
knowledge that his name too will likely
soon be back on the ballot are you still
the king maker of this Republican party
will your candidates win I hope so I
mean this President think they will I
think they're great candidates I think
they're great candidates
I really think it's been a brilliant
campaign and will you accept that will
you accept the results of this election
no answer from the former president but
his acolytes have made their feelings
clear Carrie late candidate for governor
in Arizona has been touted as a
potential running mate for Trump she
cast her vote but he's already nodding
towards election fraud
Mama also Senate candidate he's endorsed
in Pennsylvania also questions the 2020
election result if team Trump is
successful in these midterms they'll
almost certainly line up to back him in
any presidential run
his make America great again movement
once Fringe is now front and center he
wants to design the Congress and the
Senate I believe that he'll want to work
with when he runs for president again
Genie you think that then that the make
America great again team is the driving
force in this party now yeah there's no
question people like Liz Cheney Mitt
Romney the bushes those people are
marginalized and and gone from the
Republican party in terms of having a
voice for messaging but not everyone is
relishing the return of the Donald I
think he's a man who divided our country
and I think the job the greatest job of
the president is to unite the country
not divide it so I'm not a fan for that
reason
you think he'd be bad knees I think he'd
be divisive I think he's a divisive man
and I don't think we need more of that
once the nation's Premier swing state
Democrats via Florida is edging further
to the right with Republicans
capitalizing on divisive cultural issues
polls predict sweeping Republican
victories here and in many parts of the
country a red wave perhaps crashing
through the second half of Joe Biden's
presidency the power in America lies
where it always does in your hands the
hands of the people
he appeared at a rally on Monday evening
but was kept hidden from the public in
the hours before the polls closed
concern perhaps that his low opinion
polls could rub off
Trump will watch from his Mar-A-Lago
home to see how his candidates fare an
election which will determine how life
and law operates in this country for the
next two years but will have
implications far beyond that Martha
Kellner Sky News Florida